[Applause]
here's how the survey works we asked
three celebrities to complete a phrase
our first phrase was the animated movie
character I most identify with is Terry
Crews said Shrek Jennifer Lawrence said
Moana Sean Spicer said Pinocchio people
don't realize I have the ability to Jake
Gyllenhaal's said say hello in 12
languages Eva Longoria said say I love
you in 12 languages Nicolas Cage said
say sure I'll do your movie in 12
my greatest wish is for matthew
broderick said world peace Lizzy Caplan
said the United country
Mike Pence said the chance to ban
dancing in a small town if I could
travel back in time I'd Bryan Cranston
said kill Hitler Seth Rogen said kill
Hitler
Steve Bannon said have lunch with Hitler
after having my DNA analyzed I was
shocked to find out that I am 10% Don
Cheadle said Irish Tom Hanks said Native
American Gary Busey said Umbrella the
best gift ever seed this year was Jon
Hamm said a baseball autographed by Babe
Ruth Leslie Mann said a piece of
homemade art by my kids Vladimir Putin
said America
a lot of people don't know this about me
but I can Christina Hendricks said play
the accordion Neil Patrick Harris said
do magic Tommy Lee Jones said frown at
green lawns until they turn yellow
usually takes about 15 seconds size of
lawn does not matter these days these
days I think the best way to communicate
is by
Donald Trump said tweeting I've Anka
Trump said emailing Melania Trump said
writing helped me on your eyelids and
blinking real fast and finally I was at
the Senate the day we Joe Biden said
past Obamacare
Elizabeth Warren said amend the marriage
equality Act Larry King said stabbed
Julius Caesar repeatedly
he's very very
you